good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is Ingram angle from Washington
tonight it's 700 p.m. and polls have
just closed for races in two major
States first in Virginia where control
of the legislature all 140 seats it's up
for grabs as well as a slew of
Schoolboard races and other County races
and remember the outcome in the
Commonwealth of Virginia uh is one of
just four states with legislative
elections this year may be a bellweather
of what's to come in 2024 we'll see then
we have Kentucky where incumbent
Democrat Governor Andy Basher is trying
to fend off a challenge from the state's
GOP attorney general Daniel Cameron now
remember bashir's dad was also governor
and pretty popular back in 2015 now
polls are still open in Ohio for another
30 minutes or so and polls in
Mississippi close in one hour now
Governor Tate Reeves is fighting for his
second term and he's going to make his
final push right here on the angle in
moments now these elections come as
Democrat anxiety we talked a lot about
this last night is building Nationwide
as Biden's poll numbers among key
demographic groups continue to drop and
we've seen Democrats are fracturing over
the Middle East as young voters Arab
Americans are now threatening to stay
home and not vote next year and of
course they're pointing to Biden's
support for Israel as the reason some
have even given Biden a new
nickname I think he'd rather have sleepy
Joe than genocide Joe well what did
Democrats think was going to happen I
had to ask this question tonight when
they embraced the radical anti-American
left I mean they helped nurture them in
colleges and universities they knew what
they were being taught and now we have a
bunch of belligerent neoo and
professional approach protesters
essentially and now those agitators have
their own voices on Capitol Hill my
perspective is needed here now more than
ever this movement for a ceasefire is
much bigger than one person it's growing
every single day we will continue to
call for a
ceasefire movement will continue for
Liberation until every
sing has the right
to this is the place where our black and
brown staff members repeatedly speak of
experiencing racism and sexism
islamophobia get pushed off of elevators
xenophobia and more right here in this
workplace no l time is expired cease
fire now get did she say get pushed off
of
elevators and now we're hearing that
tricky dick Durban and liberal Jan
chowski are circulating a draft memo
tonight on Capitol Hill insisting that
the United States and we predicted this
was going to happen by the way that the
US should open the immigration
floodgates in Tak in Lord knows how many
gazin who are displaced by the Israeli
counter offensive yeah that's a great
idea let's import another nightmare into
our country when we can't even keep
track of the 8 million people B Biden
has already let
in and how does all of this including
the economy and all these other
important issues how does it all affect
next year's
election and how will an enfeebled
barely coherent Joe Biden stand up to
all this political pressure we're going
to unpack all of this later in the show
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else